the world has a way of changing
and we change too i know some people
there are moments that separate us
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not gonna even think
about the submarine
[Music]
now we got cars flying in the air
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family
but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
are you ready whatever's on you is you
ready it's someone else
he's got his own private army we need
help
no way
so how do you all want to play this fast
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
crank it all the way up get back with
the soldiers
we supposed to stop that hold on
and now
you spend the rest of yours
not today
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to home depot
i don't wanna die
[Music]
you